[Música]
buenos días
antes de comenzar me gustaría hacerles
una pregunta
quienes trajeron su computadora gracias
hoy al evento relevante en la mano
son muy pocos muy pocos saben que no les
puedo creer que sean tan pocos los que
hayan traído su computadora o me van a
decir que salieron de su casa muy bien
sin esto porque si a esto a lo que
llamamos teléfono celular smartphone
teléfono inteligente no es más que una
computadora además de hablar por
teléfono podemos navegar por internet
chatear jugar a los jueguitos usarlo
como despertador o como gps y si lo
abrimos dentro vamos a ver que viene uno
o varios procesadores memoria ram
memoria para guardar archivos y demás
componentes que son característicos de
una computadora
últimamente han ido apareciendo cada vez
más dispositivos en el mercado que se
nos venden como inteligentes
el reloj pulsera que además de decirnos
la hora se sincroniza con nuestro
celular nos dice la cantidad de pasos
que hicimos durante el día nos marca el
ritmo cardíaco no sean una idea
en lavarropas el televisor la aspiradora
el auto el auto que nos ayuda a
estacionar y nos dice cuál es el mejor
camino que deberíamos hacer para llegar
a nuestro destino la aspiradora que
solita va recorriendo toda la casa y
limpiando la
y yo me pregunto todos estos
dispositivos son realmente inteligentes
pueden pensar
la realidad es que no
todos estos ejemplos que les di o bien
son computadoras o bien son aparatos que
dentro tienen una o varias computadoras
y las computadoras hacen muchas pero
muchísimas cuentas a velocidades
extremadamente rápidas pero nada más
cuentas que nosotros también podríamos
resolver obviamente tomando los más
tiempo pero que tarde o temprano
podríamos resolverlo
si analizamos cada uno de los
dispositivos electrónicos que usamos
cotidianamente vamos a ver que están
compuestos por programas o aplicaciones
lo que comúnmente conocemos como
software
los programas no son inteligentes
los dispositivos tampoco son
inteligentes las personas si somos
inteligentes porque a diferencia de las
computadoras
podemos pensar y no solamente calcular
es un ejemplo de una situación que
seguramente conocen
supongan que
tenemos que hacer un sistema
que conociendo las películas y series
que una persona vio en los últimos días
o en el pasado le recomiendo que series
o películas podrían llegar a ser de su
interés
supongamos que
supongamos que sé usarlo supongamos que
yo estuve viendo la última semana el
padrino 1 y el padrino 2
qué película me debería recomendar el
sistema
claro 'apocalypse now' no es lo que
dijeron no no era no era eso qué fue lo
que pasó qué fue lo que pasó acá
bueno probablemente el criterio que
utilizaron las personas que diseñaron el
sistema no es el mismo que el nuestro
hoy que la mayoría
por ahí los programadores y las
programadoras que hicieron el sistema le
dieron más importancia al director y al
año en el que se estrenó en las
películas que por ejemplo el hecho de
que perder es una saga por eso nos
sugiere 'apocalypse now' que es una
película que se estrenó más o menos en
la misma época que el padrino 1 y
padrino 2 y no el padrino 3 es una
película que se extreme que se estrenó
15 años más tarde
les doy otro ejemplo seguramente habrán
utilizado algún sistema que les
recomienda que artículos comprar en
función de los artículos que estuvieron
viendo en el último tiempo que
estuvieron comprando selecciona conocido
a esta clase de sistemas se les conoce
como sistemas de recomendación
y es cierto que dan la sensación de que
parecieran tener un cierto
comportamiento inteligente que va
interpretando nuestros gustos pero saben
qué
estos sistemas no hacen magia
solamente siguen paso a paso las
instrucciones que un equipo de personas
les dio
personas que aprendieron cómo hacer para
darle instrucciones a una computadora
para que haga lo que nosotros queremos
que haga
y todos podemos aprender a hacerlo vos
vos y ustedes y yo todos podemos
aprender a hacerlo no hay nada
absolutamente nada que nos impida así
como aprendimos a leer y escribir así
como aprendimos a sumar ya restar
también podemos aprender a programar
de suena conocida
es una máquina de voto electrónico
algunos algunos las llaman impresoras
pero adivinan
una impresora también es una computadora
una computadora que fue programada por
personas
personas que le dieron instrucciones
para que se comporte para que funcione
de una determinada manera
y si no funciona esa determinada manera
y si tiene un error
será vulnerable esta computadora se
podrá alterar el resultado de una
elección
quienes pueden auditar este sistema
básicamente un grupo de expertos en
informática
es decir lo que hasta hoy cualquier
ciudadano podía hacer
que era verificar voto a voto que la
elección hubiese sido correcta quedaría
en manos de un pequeño grupo de personas
este es un debate muy actual sobre
ciudadanía y tecnología que se está
dando a nivel mundial saben dónde pueden
encontrar mucha información sobre este
debate
ya saben que estoy señalando
no es adiós no piense es adiós él puede
estar mucho el debate pero no me refería
a eso me refería a la nube la conocen a
la nube seguramente la conocen porque
todos los días nosotros dejamos un
montón de información en esa nube
información personal cuando por ejemplo
navegamos en las redes sociales o cuando
guardamos archivos personales ahí en la
nube
estos servicios en general son prestados
de manera gratuita
y en general son también prestados por
grandes empresas grandes empresas que
invierten muchísimo en comprar y
mantener un montón de computadoras esto
que ven acá
la nube no es esa cosita linda esponjosa
algodonosa etérea invisible esto es la
nube en realidad es parte de la nube
y entonces yo les pregunto nos dan
servicios gratuitos pero hay que
mantener todo eso son tan bondadosas y
estas empresas
o que les estaremos dando a cambio
bueno seguramente es algo que más o
menos ustedes ya deben saber porque
seguro se han leído todos los términos y
condiciones todos de punta a punta de la
primera letra hasta la última los
términos y condiciones de cada una de
las aplicaciones que se instalaron
seguro pero bueno déjenme déjame que
haga un repaso permítame leer
así todos estamos hablando de lo mismo
dice así
nos concede una licencia perpetua para
crear obras derivadas promover exponer
difundir sindicar sublicenciar
representar y mostrar públicamente el
contenido público en cualquier formato y
en cualquiera de los medios o canales de
distribución
conocidos actualmente o que se
desarrollen en el futuro
pero sigue escucha muy bien
también otorga una licencia de uso
mundial perpetua y sin restricciones
para usar tu nombre tu apariencia y tu
voz
incluyendo en relación con contenido
comercial o patrocinado
esto significa entre otras cosas que no
tendrás derecho a ninguna compensación y
que tu alma nos pertenecerá para siempre
[Música]
[Aplausos]
quizás quizás esto último el alma logre
que yo
pero el resto no es el resto es un
extracto real de los términos y
condiciones de una aplicación muy
popular hoy en día estos son serios
así que es interesante como a través de
eufemismos o metáforas marketineras como
la nubecita linda gratuita e impoluta
invisible o la inteligencia de nuestros
dispositivos nos vamos alejando cada vez
más de lo que realmente son programas
programas hechos por personas personas
que aprendieron a programar ya darle
instrucciones a una computadora
todos estos ejemplos que les fui
comentando
básicamente son ejemplos de como cada
vez más nuestra vida se ve atravesada
por el uso intensivo de sistemas
informáticos
y me gustaría preguntarles
estamos preparados para comprender este
tipo de problemas
la escuela nos está brindando las
herramientas necesarias para poder
comprender el complejo mundo tecnológico
en el que vivimos
pero germán para aquí para que contarle
a los chicos y chicas algo que ellos ya
saben ellos son nativos digitales
nacieron en la era de la tecnología y la
maneja mejor que nosotros
probablemente sean usuarios más ávidos
eso no significa que comprendan cómo
funciona esa tecnología y puedan ser
usuarios críticos
y no sabes no sabes no lo puedo creer no
lo puedo creer mi bebé es un genio
es un genio tres meses tiene meses en
meses uno dos tres meses tiene ya podéis
crear agarra la tablet y pasa las fotos
así
no no no es un genio porque puede
agarrar la tablet y pasar fotos eso no
implica necesariamente que sea un
superdotado una superdotada sino que las
interfaces de usuario se diseñan cada
vez de manera más amigable para que más
personas puedan utilizarlas
hoy en día en la mayoría de las escuelas
del país cuando nos referimos a materias
tales como computación informática o
tecnología hablamos más sobre cómo
aprender a utilizar determinado tipo de
herramientas o de aplicaciones de
oficina como puede ser la planilla de
cálculo el procesador de texto las
presentaciones con diapositivas quiero
entender cómo funcionan las computadoras
y cuáles son las ideas a aprender para
hacer nosotros mismos los creadores de
nuestros propios programas
por supuesto que está muy bien a
utilizar algo aprender a utilizar
determinado tipo de herramientas persona
debería hacer lo único
porque además
el mundo está cambiando vertiginosamente
y muchos de los empleos que hoy
conocemos ya no van a existir cuando los
chicos y chicas que hoy ingreso en el
sistema educativo deban acceder al mundo
laboral
lo que seguro no va a cambiar
es el uso cada vez más intensivo de la
tecnología
por eso por eso tenemos que aprender
cómo funcionan las computadoras y cómo
funcionan los programas y no solamente
ser meros usuarios de aplicaciones y
como les dije todos podemos aprender y
se los garantizo yo hace más de cinco
años tengo trabajando en un proyecto
para que más y más chicos docentes
directivos y supervisores de todo el
país aprendan a programar
y saben una cosa
no solamente superan todas las
expectativas sino que también disfrutan
haciéndolo algo que es fundamental algo
que es necesario cuando uno está
aprendiendo algo
y tenemos que seguir por este camino
profundizando lo
por supuesto no soy yo solo somos un
equipo cada vez más grande de personas a
lo largo y ancho del país estamos
generando
estamos generando un montonazo de
material didáctico para trabajar en el
aula
por qué
si no nos anticipamos a los grandes
cambios a nivel laboral que ya están
sucediendo
sino problematiza mos sobre los grandes
debates sobre tecnología que están
ocurriendo hoy en día
si no enseñamos a comprender cómo
funcionan las herramientas informáticas
que utilizamos todos los días y sobre
las cuales basamos un montón de nuestras
decisiones
estamos formando ciudadanos críticos
para vivir en esta era
en la escuela del presente aprender a
programar tiene que ser una realidad
cuanto más vamos a esperar muchas
gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]